My name is Ahmed Farah. I am a part-time
marketing freelancer and entrepreneur.
Uh I have two simple questions.
>> One at a time, brother. We allow only
one question at a time. Please ask your
first question.
>> Okay. Thank you. Um my my question since
I've been involved with um uh interfaith
discussions with my non-Muslim friends,
I have u two difficult questions that I
can't answer. So maybe you can help me.
>> Can you please go ahead and ask your ask
your first question?
>> So uh there is one sah a hadith that
says that we those who leave Islam can
be killed.
Um and doesn't it contradict to the
Quranic verse that uh there's no
compulsion in religion. So how do you
reconcile that? Thank you.
>> There was asked a question that there is
a which says that those who leave Islam
they should be killed and the verse of
the Quran is referring to surah bakra 2
verse number 256 which says
there's no compulsion. So isn't there a
contradiction when Allah says in the
Quran there is no compulsion religion
means you cannot force anyone to accept
Islam at the point of the sword. You
cannot take a gun and tell him except
Islam. You can't take a sword. So then
you cannot force anyone to accept Islam.
That is true. So if you force anyone to
accept Islam, it is haram.
That is another question
that once you accept Islam, you have
agreed to follow the rules and
regulation of the religion. There's a
difference between the two. You cannot
force anyone to accept Islam. That's not
permitted. But someone who accepts the
dean,
he a Muslim, then he leaves the dean,
he's going from the right track to the
wrong track. This Islam does not permit.
And why Islam says that he does they
don't want a person to go from good to
bad.
Islam agrees that Islam is h you cannot
force anyone to accept but once you
accept it is the rule you have to
follow. For example,
no one can force you to join a school.
Correct?
>> Yes.
>> Can someone force you? No. But once you
join the school then you have to wear
the uniform or not.
>> Yes. You have to respect the teacher or
not.
>> Yes.
>> You have to appear for the examination
or not.
>> Yes.
>> If you do bad, you have then you'll fail
or not.
>> 100%.
>> Now, why you're failing me?
We not forcing anyone is a different
concept. You can't force anyone for him
to accept the dean and that also you're
quoting half like
there's no compulsion. Truth stands out
clear from error. Whosoever holds the
hand of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala, he
will take you darkness from light. He
will take you from darkness to light. If
you hold the hand of the Satan, he will
take you darkness to light.
So, he'll take you from light to
darkness. The Satan complete the full
versing half. So there's no compulsion
in anyone. You cannot force anyone to
accept Islam. But once out of free will
he accepts, then he has to follow the
rules and regulation of the religion.
And we would not want anyone to devalue
himself from going outside the deen. So
that's I agree with the logic that we
should not allow anyone to devalue
himself. So that's the reason these are
the rules laid down by Allah subhanaa
tala. Hope that answers the question.
>> But why do I need to be punished? Why do
I need to be killed if I want to leave
Islam?
>> If you take admission into the school
then you'll fail. Why should I be
failed?
Why should you be failed
>> in this? There are two views. One view
is a person like in the country. You
know there something like treason.
You know treason.
>> No.
>> Treason means you're selling
the secrets of the country to the enemy.
from
if you do that most of the country
death penalty or life imprisonment. If
you do you cannot say why is this
country giving me death penalty? Why did
you do that mistake?
Can you argue?
>> No. No. I want to do it. I want to sell.
No. Why? This is the law of the country.
Why did you become a citizen of the
country?
But I cannot do that to somebody else
who's not a citizen of the country. Do
you understand?
>> Yes.
>> So these are rules of the country.
They're logical.
And this is to help the person stay on
the straight path.
Allah wants a person to go to Jenna. So
that is the reason these are deterrence
so that he stays on the straight path.
Those person who don't
know what is the beauty of Islam, he may
think it's illogical.
I'm asking a question. Your son wants to
jump from the 10story building. I saw
Superman. Will you allow?
Will you allow?
>> No.
>> No. But freedom is there. Let your son
jump. He say I'm Superman. Superman
jump. He doesn't die. What will you do?
Allow him to jump.
>> No.
>> Why?
>> Because you're a very harsh father.
>> Maybe you slap him also. Correct. Yeah.
>> Why? Why you want to slap him?
>> Yeah. Because I would rather slap him as
opposed to
>> rather than he dies.
>> Yeah.
>> Here also better you die rather than you
go to hell. Do you understand?
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> Otherwise you go to hell. So we don't
want Muslim people to go to hell.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Hope that answers the question.
Thank you.